parlons des vrais sujets estce que
l'émotion qu'est-ce que fasse un casach
les larmes aux yeux un
cachx non ça c'est extraordinaire ça
c'est chouette de montrer des trucs
comme ça parce que les gens ne savent
pas forcément heureusement pour eux
d'ailleurs euh donc ça Hugo on va
montrer sur toi donc ça ben justement
s'il y a une scène de de de coit bah il
il y a quand même la pudeur et puis puis
si jamais il faut se toucher bref donc
bah voilà on applique ça et du coup ça
veut dire que ça on a quand même de
l'autre côté et alors c'est c'est grand
sens esthétique déjà c'est vraiment
chouette déplac avec ça vraiment super
ça m'a pas tellement manqué de travaill
de travailler de de pas travailler
pendant un an j'imagine